how are you doing sir
i'm good good to see you nice to see you
i have too many questions in 10 minutes
let's see what the hell i can do uh
first thing
uh uh what tv series would you love to
guest
direct oh uh
mad men what is your favorite dish at
your father's restaurant
well i i like boring dishes but it's uh
well
the lobster garlic noodles those are
pretty good
uh when did you feel like you made it as
a director
that you would continue to book projects
and
you'd like you made it uh
i felt maybe not that i made it because
i don't i don't know what that means
exactly other than
i knew that i uh belonged here and i
knew what i was doing
um after now you see me too
was there any chance of that thing
called uh being called now you don't
that's an ongoing joke about you know
now you see me now you don't
we tried very hard to call it now you
don't but the marketing department
this is true said we don't like the word
don't
in a title and we're like uh
this is like the perfect literal title
and they were like no
we're calling it now you see me too like
can we give it like an
extra word or something but
always wondered that um listen i like
heart when i see that because i'm like
yeah we should have called it that i
agree
um look i have to ask you this because i
thought the first film was so good
um what is the status of the crazy rich
asian sequels
uh in the heights is the crazy sequel
i'm getting no i'm believing
in the heights it's [ __ ] awesome i'm
getting to it um
but i we're working on it it needs to be
great for us to drag everybody back
there's no way i'm coming back unless
it's great and uh
it's it's getting there got it so you
don't have scripts that you're happy
with yet
i we have scripts that we're working on
in progress
i understand um how did working on the
step up films
prepare you for making in the heights
it introduced me to uh street dancers
of all styles
ages play places they're from i got to
be they became some of my best friends
i got to hang out with them see how they
what their lifestyle is i got to
understand why they created their styles
because a lot of them created their own
so they didn't go to like a school
for it um and i got to know them at the
most human personal level
and i got to learn because as us working
together on side projects
that a camera can ruin their
storytelling and a camera can also
help and enhance their storytelling if
we were both telling
if we knew what the storytelling we were
trying to do together and that we could
do great work together
and so for me this language of movement
in in the heights was that was
imperative to understand how we could
use that and and then you add music on
top of that and lyrics and
song um i felt like i um
i had already done a lot of experiments
of of how not to make it a performance
but instead have it come from the spot
that it originated from which was
uh through through them one of the
things i think the film does so well
is the filming on location i think it
adds just so much to telling this story
i know this had to have been a battle uh
to film on location
so can you talk a little bit about the
battles you had to overcome to make it
happen
well the good thing is when we got out
of the weinstein company
uh and and and lin's hamilton had become
so
big and crazy rich asians uh was hitting
um it became very clear that we could uh
we could dictate
that we were going to be shooting in
washington heights no matter what
um so we didn't have to battle that much
ultimately
of course once we got there then you're
like is this actually possible can you
close
you know when you're in an intersection
you have to close two blocks on the left
two blocks on the right two blocks to
the north two blocks to the south like
that's a giant swath of people to shut
down their parking for
and um you know we worked we
through lynn and louise and the whole
community we we sat down and had a long
conversation with them how to make it
make it right
i'm assuming that the people in the
community and correct me if i'm wrong
they had to have also looked at it like
this is a great opportunity to highlight
this community
and to raise the profile i'm sure people
are going to see the movie and want to
go there and
see where it was filmed uh maybe and i'm
not sure everybody wants that to be
honest you know after the after the
joker stairs
um so so there was a piece of it that
was like
um it's more about sharing
sharing your values sharing who works
here putting people on a
pedestal of of working hard hey that guy
on the corner who owns the bodega is
someone you should be looking up to
because he works hard for his family um
and his dreams and his hopes are bigger
than
any movie that you've seen uh recently
and he deserves that space to have that
so in a way that was the cell
more than um hey you're going to get a
lot of more tourists over here i think
that wasn't the best
way but lynn and again lynn and louise
and chiara who all are of that
neighborhood
uh they led the way on on how how to
make this movie right uh i'm fascinated
by the editing process because it's the
final rewrite it's where it all comes
together
talk a little bit about any challenges
you had in the editing room
and who did you trust for honest
feedback to know that hey this is
working
well maya and kirsten are our editor who
did crazy with chase as well he's like
my spirit animal
i used to edit a i i did a lot growing
growing up so i
i shoot like an editor i'm i'm not
making the movie when we're shooting
i'm collecting the all all the
ingredients and juicing the
juicing the fruit and trying to get all
the stuff and so that i can bring it
into the edit room
and we can see what spices to add where
what sugar to add
and so to have a master chef like myron
who's done stuff like garden state and
uh and things like that to me is like he
understands the spectacle but he really
understands
um the nuances of of small moments and i
often won't cut
i'll just keep shooting so let's do it
again let's do it again and usually it's
the moments in between
those weird natural things that that
people do
that are the juice and uh he looks for
that he watches every frame and so
um that was a that was a i i honestly
already trust him on just finding the
juice
and then the second thing is when we
work together we're very honest with
each other
um i can see something and
um i can get granular or i can challenge
him and say i don't feel for the
character
by the time he walks out of this room
i'll leave for the day
make me care for him and he can do four
different versions of how much i'll care
for him and i'll we'll zero in on the
one that he does he loves to
cut and and we know the power of the
edit so
changing the order of stuff and we did
some some of that stuff in the movie
uh makes a huge difference and we had it
on the wall and in the wall we had um
even before shooting um instead of just
the plot points we had the emotion
so this is yearning this one's about
being alone this is about
connecting and then we'd have every
department come in and i'd say this
scene even though it's about him doing
this that
it's actually about yearning so you guys
use your art
to tell that part of the story of
yearning and and that was really helpful
for us in the edit room
i think that's also one of the reasons
the film is so special uh
being honest um i definitely have to ask
you how has your
in the heights experience maybe prepped
you or helped you
shape what you want to do with wicked
you knew i was going to ask this
or maybe maybe you knew we're we're in
the beginning stages of wicked however
i think the philosophy of what musicals
mean to me personally now that i have
actually made a movie musical
you know there's theory about what movie
musicals mean to me as being a
watcher of movie musicals now that i've
gone through it it really
the what really has hit me is the power
of music and why musicals exist in the
first place because work when words
aren't sufficient
and nowadays words really aren't
sufficient for
what we're going through and and so for
me it's finding the truth
of each song um and working our way
inside out of why that exists yes of
course we're going to have oz
and you're going to be in this crazy
world and you're going to revisit this
innocent place and you're going to see
that it's
not as innocent as it had been in the
past but you're also going to see
um that the relationship between these
two women
is is more real than ever that we're
going to be that close to them we're
going to
root for them when to try to get into
that school or or when one crosses the
other we're going to root that they
you're going to hate the other one at
some point you're going to want them to
make up at another point you're going to
feel when they separate to me that's
like that's the most important thing the
spectacle that's the easy part we can
hire a lot of people to do that
uh it's it's those little moments who
are gonna be able to communicate those
moments
uh that's that's good what's gonna make
that i have to rap but do you think
you're filming this year
i can't answer that i'll leave your v
hey listen man you did such a great job
with this i wish you nothing but the
best
thank you sam appreciate you thanks for
everything you do always